I'm here with the Virgil senescu who
made the first move today here at super
bat he is the five-time best player best
basketball player in Romania and the
national captain welcome to the show
visually tell us a little bit about you
and your connection with chess thank you
very much thank you for the introduction
my connection with chess is on amateur
level I played in of course preparations
and all this time that we have away from
home we did enjoy some here and there a
game of chess I played basketball for 20
years
this is the first place that actually
people asked me did you come to chess
other than that it's mostly you play
basketball right because of 2:08 is I
don't know if the Chess Championship saw
another 2:08
but I enjoyed being here and watch this
beautiful minds in inaction I did the
first move which we'll see how it turns
out at the end of the game but that's
pretty much about a big guy on the chess
board do you see any similarities
between chess and basketball may be
psychological similarities during a game
may be training similarities it's a
strategy game and we do have not not
many people know how many plays we have
in in basketball and how you react we
every place oh yes there are many
similarities you plan ahead strategy you
reorient certain moments you analyze of
course it's a totally different speed as
we were in the Blitz game right here
what I understand in blitz is a little
different than what is here about blades
and but but other than that it's it's a
great game and defense like this speaks
volume for for the country for the for
the kids for the
math level and for everything and last
and last but not least who is your
favorite I'm sure you've maybe analyzed
some of the players that are playing
here who is your favorite we to win this
event well of course we have a number
two in the world that everybody's
focused on but everybody here is you
don't have underdogs and you don't have
you don't have people that say okay
you're your deadbeat you come here and
you're you know so I think it's open
we'll see you then
awesome thank you very much for joining
us thank you guys back to you
you